son las 8:30 de la noche en Bogotá quito
y Lima continuamos en directo América
edición nocturna Les agradecemos su
sintonía y vamos con los titulares de
esta jornada
en declaraciones posteriores al anuncio
del gobierno francés de aprobar la
reforma las pensiones sin la votación de
la asamblea nacional la primera ministra
Elizabeth aseguró que fue un recurso
extremo tras tratar de reunir una
mayoría legislativa que diera luz verde
a la controversial normativa miles de
personas protestaron en las calles donde
se presentaron choques con la policía
Polonia anunció que enviará en los
próximos días cuatro aviones de combate
mig 29 a Ucrania y se convertirá así en
el primer Aliado de la otan en entregar
este tipo de armamento entre tanto la
misión de la ONU en Ucrania descartó que
Rusia Cometa un genocidio con la guerra
pero destacó que sí hay numerosos
crímenes de guerra y contra la humanidad
la oposición ecuatoriana activó el
pedido de juicio político contra el
presidente Guillermo lasso a quien
señalan de presunta corrupción y
malversación de fondos aún falta una
revisión de la corte constitucional que
Determine si la denuncia está
debidamente fundamentada y es procedente
ampliamos desde quito
[Aplausos]
[Música]
comenzamos en Francia donde continúa la
atención luego de que el gobierno de
Manuel macón anunciara que activara un
mecanismo que le permite al ejecutivo
aprobar la controversial reforma a las
pensiones sin la votación de la asamblea
nacional en declaraciones a la cadena
tfm la primera ministra Elizabeth Boss
nos resaltó que la medida es extrema y
el gobierno tuvo que tomarla tras horas
de negociaciones en las que intentaron
conseguir el apoyo legislativo con el
que no cuenta el gobierno en la asamblea
el anuncio del ejecutivo de aprobar la
normativa generó multitudinarias
protestas en el país en varias zonas se
presentaron choques entre las
autoridades y los manifestantes
lo que les puedo decir es que hasta el
último minuto con mis ministros hicimos
todo lo que pudimos para juntar una
mayoría en esta ley ya saben con el
presidente de la república queríamos ir
a una votación no es un tema personal de
lo que estamos hablando es de un
elemento crucial de nuestro modelo
Social es nuestra capacidad de
reformarlo para asegurar su
sostenibilidad
el mecanismo aplicado por el gobierno
francés para evitar el debate
parlamentario en la asamblea nacional y
sacar adelante su polémica reforma las
pensiones es recurrir al artículo 49 3
de la Constitución Sin embargo a la
medida todavía da capacidad a la
oposición para presentar una moción de
censura todo ello en medio de las
continuas protestas y la atención que
han vuelto a una de las propuestas más
controvertidas de Manuel macón veamos
más en el informe de Marta Moya
primero fue el Sí en el senado francés y
luego el gobierno impidió el debate en
la asamblea nacional al inicio de la
sesión cuando ya se conocía la decisión
Del ejecutivo tras la filtración a un
medio de comunicación los diputados de
la oposición empezaron a entonar la
marsellesa
[Aplausos]
la primera ministra Elizabeth born
finalmente invocó el artículo 49-3 de la
Constitución para dar luz verde a la
reforma pensional del gobierno de Manuel
macrón
no podemos jugarnos el futuro de
nuestras pensiones esta reforma es
necesaria por lo tanto sobre la base del
artículo 49 párrafo tres de la
Constitución comprometo la
responsabilidad de mi gobierno sobre el
conjunto del proyecto de ley de la
Reforma de seguridad Social para 2023
modificado por la enmienda de
coordinación comunicada a la asamblea
nacional
Pero qué es este artículo Y por qué le
da esta potestad al gobierno el Primer
Ministro podrá previa deliberación del
Consejo de ministros comprometer la
responsabilidad del gobierno ante la
asamblea nacional en la votación de un
proyecto de ley de finanzas o de
financiación de la seguridad social en
este caso el proyecto de ley se
considera adoptado A menos que se
apruebe una moción de censura presentada
en las 24 horas siguientes el Primer
Ministro podrá además recurrir a este
procedimiento para otro proyecto o
proposición de ley por periodo de
sesiones de este modo al menos diez
partes del total de la asamblea nacional
deben ponerse de acuerdo para presentar
una moción de censura en las 24 horas
posteriores a la aplicación del artículo
una moción que luego debe ser ratificada
por la mayoría absoluta del parlamento
para hacer caer al gobierno este jueves
El Ejecutivo marcó otro hito ya que es
la vez número 100 que se aplica el 49 3
en la quinta República concretamente
Elizabeth born es la segunda jefa de
gobierno que más veces lo ha puesto en
marcha 11
ahora la asamblea y las calles tendrán
que dar su palabra sobre el
controvertido proyecto de ley que
pretende aumentar la edad de jubilación
de los 62 a los 64 años y que ha
movilizado a millones de personas contra
la propuesta desde hace semanas Polonia
anunció que entregará cuatro aviones de
combate mig 29 a Ucrania en los próximos
días y la cifra puede aumentar en las
próximas semanas así lo anunció el
gobierno con lo que Polonia se convierte
en el primer integrante de la otan en
enviar este tipo de armamento al
ejecutivo de kieveza
Polonia se convirtió en el primer
miembro de la otan que proporciona
aviones de combate a Ucrania mientras
continúa defendiéndose de las tropas del
kremlin el jueves el presidente andrey
duda dijo que Varsovia proporcionará
alrededor de una docena de aviones de
combate mig 29 de La Era soviética para
reforzar a Ucrania en la guerra el
primer envío entrará en servicio de
manera inminente
estos jets están en sus últimos años de
servicio de acuerdo con sus
posibilidades técnicas pero en la
mayoría de los casos todavía están en
buenas condiciones de funcionamiento en
los próximos días entregaremos cuatro
aviones a Ucrania todos en perfectas
condiciones de funcionamiento los otros
aviones están siendo revisados y
preparados para ser entregados
gradualmente
con la guerra al otro lado de su
frontera Polonia ha asumido un papel
central en la movilización del
suministro occidental de armas a Ucrania
pero la entrega de casas de fabricación
rusa es un gran paso sin necesidad de
entrenamiento adicional para los pilotos
ucranianos es probable que los cazas de
la era soviética se pongan en uso
durante meses el presidente zelensky ha
estado pidiendo un mayor poder aéreo
para defender los cielos de su país pero
su gobierno está pidiendo que se
suministre en casas f-16 más modernos
los mix no resolverán las tareas
necesitamos f-16 pero los mix sí
ayudarán a fortalecer nuestras
capacidades
El guardián de las llaves de esos f-16
es Estados Unidos pero hasta ahora
Washington ha resistido la presión para
entregar cualquier avión incluso a la
luz de la decisión de Polonia sin
embargo otros países pronto podrían
seguir su ejemplo hay rumores de que
otras naciones han acordado enviar casas
de Última Generación como parte de un
acuerdo de coalición más amplio y las
fuentes sugieren que Eslovaquia podría
ser el próximo en enviar sus aviones un
movimiento que el Antiguo estado
satélite soviético había sugerido en el
pasado
justamente este jueves la misión de
Naciones Unidas que Investiga posibles
violaciones a los derechos humanos en
Ucrania presentó su más reciente reporte
en el que asegura que las fuerzas rusas
han cometido crímenes de guerra y contra
la humanidad con un brutal desprecio por
la vida de los civiles el texto señala
además que los delitos incluyen
asesinatos tortura y tratos inhumanos
violaciones y deportaciones forzosas en
nueve regiones investigadas cuatro más
que el reporte previo por el contrario
el ente explica que no hay pruebas de
que Rusia esté cometiendo un Exterminio
de la población ucraniana
en cuanto a sus primeras preguntas sobre
el genocidio no hemos encontrado que
haya habido un genocidio dentro de
Ucrania
hemos notado que hay algunos aspectos
que pueden generar dudas con respecto a
ese crimen por ejemplo ciertas
declaraciones en los medios rusos que
están dirigidas a grupos
pero aún no Hemos llegado a conclusión
continuaremos con esto
cambiamos de tema y vamos a Ecuador
donde la oposición activo el proceso de
juicio político contra el presidente
Guillermo lasso a quien señalan de
proteger a personas cercanas a él y al
oficialismo en un presunto entramado de
corrupción en empresas públicas para
ampliar esta información conectamos con
Gustavo Ortega les corresponsal de
France 24 en Quito Gustavo se activa el
proceso y qué pasos siguen ya es un
hecho que habrá juicio político
Hola buenas noches Sí con 59 46 firmas
requeridas para solicitar formalmente el
juicio político la bancada oposición ha
presentado ante la gestión documental de
la asamblea nacional el pedido para
enjuiciar así el presidente de la
república presenta esta solicitud de
juicio político cuatro de las cinco
bancadas que hacen en vida en la
asamblea nacional el partido unes que
convoca a el correísmo el partido social
cristiano que eran antiguos aliados al
presidente de la república una fracción
del pachacútec el cual agrupa los
movimientos indígenas y la izquierda
democrática formalmente comienzan así lo
que es la solicitud de juicio político
contra el presidente de la república
posteriormente Entonces qué es lo que va
a pasar será un hecho o no Bueno esto
debe cumplir con un procedimiento por
parte de la normativa legal del Ecuador
ya el presidente de la asamblea nacional
Virgilio tiene tres días para presentar
ante el órgano calificador de la
asamblea nacional este pedido de juicio
político ante este órgano que
posteriormente debe revisar si cumple
con los requisitos de ley para
presentarlo ante la Corte constitucional
posteriormente entonces la corte
constitucional debe decidir en un
período de seis días Si cumple o no con
estos requisitos legales para indicar si
habrá o no un juicio político en total
de considerar positivo para comenzar con
juicio político el presidente de
república podría ser destituido pero un
proceso que se extenderá por 55 días
Bueno acusan a lazo de presunta
corrupción y malversación Pero entonces
qué han dicho desde el ejecutivo tras
este anuncio
bueno específicamente el informe
presentado ante la asamblea nacional
dice que actualmente el que el
presidente de la república conocía sobre
ciertas investigaciones que en principio
conformaron parte de una investigación
de tráfico de drogas y posteriormente
también ha tenido puntos que es
resaltado el presidente de la república
a solapado una investigación que tenía
conocimiento y que ha defendido a su
entorno
íntimo y ha solapado también
investigaciones de presunta corrupción
en la empresa pública dice
específicamente el documento y Leo
textualmente nosotros establecemos
responsabilidades políticas y hemos
presentado este juicio político porque
los hechos fácticos y se relacionan
circunstancialmente De igual forma se
dispone a actuar de acuerdo a la
Constitución y se dice ha protegido
vínculos de una estructura criminal en
las empresas públicas Pero qué es lo que
dice El Ejecutivo nacional Hace algunos
minutos El Ejecutivo nacional ha emitido
un pronunciamiento formal en rechazo a
este juicio político y dice
específicamente se rechaza el juicio
político carece de sustentos tanto
políticos como jurídico para sustentar
así un proceso en contra el presidente
de la república por el cual considera
que este juicio político tiene
exclusivamente intenciones
desestabilizadoras encontradas
democracia ha dicho Hace algunos minutos
el gobierno nacional Gustavo usted
muchas gracias por esta ampliación
estamos muy pendientes de lo que ocurra
en Ecuador y el presidente de Colombia
Gustavo Petro informó que ascendió a 21
el número de Mineros fallecidos tras la
explosión ocurrida en la noche del
martes en seis minas de carbón
interconectadas en el centro del país de
esta manera las autoridades declararon
el fin de las labores de búsqueda y
rescate siete personas salieron por sus
propios medios y dos fueron rescatadas
con vida al momento de la emergencia
había 30 trabajadores en el interior de
Las Minas
y pasamos a Perú donde la temporada de
lluvias ha dejado al menos 59 muertos y
cerca de 12.000 damnificados desde
septiembre en los últimos días el ciclón
yaku ha provocado inundaciones y
deslizamientos de tierra obligando al
gobierno a declarar el estado de
emergencia Alba Santana nos amplía agua
y más agua escenarios como este han
marcado los últimos días de muchos
peruanos el ciclón yaku se saldó con
inundaciones acompañadas de fuertes
vientos a su paso que solo en la región
de Lima ya han dejado a más de tres mil
personas sin casa
o sea solamente con la ropa
nada más y sigo también igual mis nietos
igual y como usted ve Ahora a poder
levantarme de nuevo pase de trabajo pero
con cubos algunos intentan despejar las
inundaciones para salvar sus viviendas y
pertenencias Y es que la temporada de
lluvias que comenzó en septiembre ha
causado muchos estragos en el país
sudamericano con decenas de muertos Y al
menos 12.000 damnificados han dicho
defensa civil que tenemos que subir por
lo que vivimos todos al contorno de Río
para prevención porque para que no nos
pase ya nada los equipos de rescate se
han tenido que desplegar en las zonas
más afectadas y escenas como esta
se han vuelto cada vez a más comunes
para intentar garantizar la seguridad de
la gente de la zona no tenemos nada como
perdimos todo absolutamente todo el
ciclón denominado como no organizado y
estrechamente relacionado con el
fenómeno de la niña ha pillado las
autoridades a peruanas por sorpresa y ha
obligado al gobierno de Dina boluarte a
declarar estado de emergencia en 400
distritos del país entre tanto en Chile
los empleados de la confederación
nacional de trabajadores municipales de
la salud se declararon en huelga para
exigir una mejora en sus condiciones
laborales en Santiago la capital los
manifestantes corearon consignas y hasta
se encadenaron a la entrada del
Ministerio de salud le solicitan al
gobierno que resuelva los problemas
relacionados con la ley de retiro y el
decreto de un Bono de emergencia
cerramos en el desierto de alula en el
noroeste de Arabia Saudita donde se
llevó a cabo la carrera inaugural de la
camel Cup donde como su nombre lo dice
los competidores son camellos el premio
acumulado es de 21 millones de dólares y
se dice que la carrera es la más grande
y costosa de la región propietarios y
creadores de camellos de diferentes
partes del mundo llevan a sus ejemplares
a competir en el evento que va hasta el
17 de marzo
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
directo a América aquí en France 24 a
ustedes Les agradecemos su sintonía y
los invitamos a continuar con nosotros
que ya llega Gabriel colchón con toda la
información de oriente medio en Expreso
de oriente feliz noche para todos
[Música]